Ah ! Un parfum !
Ah non,
c'est un déo.
Efficacité 48 heures.
Bah merci, c'est cool !
Et des chewing-gums
menthol ultra-puissants !
Heu, merci !
Ah ! Une chemise ! T'as gardé le ticket ?
Non, juste au cas où j'ai envie d'aller
la changer ou peut-être même la rendre.
Tiens ! C'est moi
qui l'ai fait pour toi !
Oh, un collier de nouilles !
Mais c'est de la merde !
Attends, je t'ai offert
un Action Man à 200 balles,
et tu m'offres cette daube
en pâtes pourries à un centime !
Tu te fous de ma gueule !
T'es plus mon fils, OK !
Je vais t'abandonner sur l'autoroute
comme une vieille crotte !
Ah cool, une BD !
Attends, je vais lire un petit passage.
Bibliothèque Municipale de Bagnolet,
à rendre le 8 janvier.
Ouais ! D'ailleurs, si tu peux le lire
assez vite, ça m'arrange.
Ah OK !
Euh, mec,
c'est mon chien, ça !
Ouais, je sais, mais au moins,
je me suis dit que tu serais pas déçu.
Oh ! J'y crois pas !
Tu m'as offert un ordinateur...
...éducatif !
Hey ! Tu adores surfer sur Internet,
regarder des films ou même jouer à des jeux vidéo.
Grâce à l'ordinateur éducatif,
tout ça est impossible.
C'est de la merde !
Pas Internet.
Pas de jeux vidéo.
Plein d'exercices
comme à l'école.
Et un écran
en noir et blanc.
Ha ha ha !
J'apprends à faire des additions !
J'ai trouvé le synonyme de Louis.
Avec l'ordinateur éducatif,
apprends sans t'amuser !
Oh ! C'est Mamie qui m'a envoyé une petite carte
avec un petit chaton trop mignon, c'est adorable !
Y a pas de chèque ?
Y a pas de chèque !
Bah je m'en bats les couilles, alors !
Cadeau suivant !
Moi, à la base,
je suis plus tout ce qui est —
Stop ! Stop ! C'est bon !
Mais c'est le Père Noël
qui me l'a offert !
Ouais, bah, parfois, le Père Noël,
il annule les cadeaux. Là, c'est annulé !
Ouais, moi, j'adore la Bretagne,
surtout les huîtres. Ouais !
Et le prix du meilleur acteur, dans la catégorie
"Je fais semblant d'aimer mon cadeau de Noël"
revient à Norman,
pour le couteau de fromage.
Excellent !
Revoyons les images !
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Oh ! Un couteau à fromage !
Merci !
Merci ! J'adore le fromage en plus,
ça tombe bien ! Merci !
C'est un très beau livre qui retrace
toute l'histoire des Mérovingiens,
notamment ce moment où Clovis
perd son glaive en pleine bataille !
D'accord. Ah ouais, d'accord !
OK, donc en fait, ouais !
Ah excellent ! C'est exactement le même panneau
qu'il y a dans ma rue devant chez moi.
C'est— Ah bah apparemment,
il est plus là.
C'est un petit bonsaï que j'ai ramené
de mon voyage au Japon.
D'accord.
Il mesure combien ?
Oh, je sais pas,
il mesure 45 cm.
Et il pèse combien ?
Je sais pas,
je dirais 500 grammes.
C'est bon,
c'est en vente sur Ebay.
Ah !
C'est énorme !
C'est quoi ?
C'est un pin's ?
C'est un beau pin's !
Tadaam ! La fameuse !
Je sais que tu la voulais.
J'ai fait graver ton nom
dessus en lettres d'or.
C'est une édition collector
unique au monde,
mais je l'ai achetée rien que pour toi,
parce que t'es mon pote !
Moi aussi, j'avais un cadeau pour toi,
mais c'est pas celui-là, ça, c'est autre chose.
J'irais une autre fois le chercher.
C'était un cadeau,
un autre truc.
Mieux que toi.
Ça me choque toujours un peu de voir quelqu'un
recevoir une bouteille d'alcool pour Noël.
Tu sais, j'imagine pas du tout le Père Noël
préparer ce genre de cadeau.
Nicolas, tu as été sage cette année,
alors je te mets une bouteille de Sky,
un deux litres de vodka
et un gros bout de barrette
de shit de banlieue.
Hé ! Joyeux Noël
ma gueule !
En tout cas,
le plus important à Noël,
c'est pas les cadeaux,
mais c'est d'être réunis ensemble.
Alors une petite pensée
pour ceux qui malheureusement
sont tous seuls
cette année encore à Noël.
Et puis moi, j'aimerais
faire un petit cadeau
pour ceux qui malheureusement
ont pas la chance d'en avoir.
Alors, attention,
roulement de tambour !
C'est vraiment horrible !
J'aimerais offrir tout simplement
dix places de spectacle,
mon spectacle
"Norman sur scène",
à ceux qui ont pas la chance
d'avoir des cadeaux.
Dites-le dans les commentaires
et puis je vous en offre par tirage au sort.
Voilà ! Joyeux Noël !
Alors, je vais vous prendre un petit
sirop de papaye bio sans gluten
et une clé USB 32 Go, si possible
compatible avec mon MacBook Pro.
Thanks !